Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh right no longer in the competition
welcome back to unmasking the masked
singer it is a day 4720 one of
quarantine but we're still here sticking
with you riding all the way through on
Deidre Behar here with my friend hello
I'm Charlie O'Keefe and tonight was the
semi-finals giving us something to look
forward to here in self-isolation let's
kick it off by saying goodbye to our
favorite safari animal
[Applause]
no I just had such a great time and this
the show has stretched me in so many
ways
Charlie this is a very exciting moment
for us our sweet sweet friend Barry Zito
aka Barry tortellini as we
affectionately call him I know we like
to be spirited every week unfortunately
I don't have any Rhino themed things at
home but I do have pasta which is some
it's rotini so it's in the pen I feel
like a baseball would have worked as
well but I know neither of us have this
sporty spice I am NOT um but let's let's
have a moment and cheers to Barry Zito
this is someone who really went through
an emotional journey on the program he
said in every single clue package that
it was about reinvention it was about
hard days and then triumphs and family
and and he seemed to have such a
positive experience on the show and
hopefully he'll use it to catapult even
further into his music career as this
like second phase of life or his career
I guess you could say what did you think
I think it goes to show you don't have
to be a singer naturally or someone who
comes from that career first to be on
the map here I mean we had Gronk from
the NFL and Barry has obviously dabbled
in music before but I think it's cool to
see him in this performing light which
we haven't really gotten used to seeing
a man yeah he's definitely a new artist
to me of course Charlie and I have have
made it very clear we really weren't
familiar with Barry's Ito's work but if
you're a sports mean you obviously know
who he is and hopefully people who watch
the mask singer are now also fans of
Barry Zito the guy has an unbelievable
voice and so much star power I am so
excited to see what he does next and
it's official we finally have our top
three contestants for season three of
the masked singer Dee drama you like
it's been 9,000 weeks of waiting for
this moment
it's been a long season but a good one
correct we officially have the night
angel at the Frog and the turtle moving
forward to the finale next week but
kicking it off tonight we have the night
angel who showed us how to love her even
more in the competition
[Music]
if this is kandi Burruss behind the
night angel mask we've been saying week
after week covering a little Wayne
classic I don't even know what's doing
with myself I honestly am beside myself
just when I think she's done my favorite
performance she goes and does something
even more insane and completely crushes
it are you okay are you breathing the
woman no I'm literally not the woman
loves range people she has ranged she's
back I was swiping entreprenuers she
could do a little weight she she could
quite literally do anything and earlier
in the show believable I digress let's
get into her clue package tonight of
course it was actually a sad clue
package lots of references to loss you
know that the night angel was talking
about a guardian angel suffering a loss
that really impacted her so if you know
candy you know that she was formerly
engaged to AJ Jewell he died in 2009 in
Atlanta after getting into a brawl
outside of a club so of course it has
been about 10 years and candy has
remarried but that stuff never ever gets
any easier and it she kind of turned it
into a positive but that he's now her
guardian angel and is inspiring her to
do these things they get her outside of
her comfort zone a little bit
the other big clue from the clue package
were these two sports balls so you get a
soccer ball on screen next to a football
on screen and follow me here with my
sports knowledge those are two balls
that you kick so I'm thinking did candy
maybe perform at a sporting event or
something well here's what I got her
band xscape they actually have a huge
hit called just kicking it take a listen
[Music]
deidre I mean I think that's pretty
accurate and sports evidence we're great
at it I do want to point out that you
don't always kick footballs only in
field goals you know what I don't know
what that means but sounds great and
let's just go we didn't just kick it the
xscape song there we go and moving
forward tonight we saw something
different we saw a closer look clue so
there was a ramp actually on the stage
leading right up to the judge's table
and the contestants got very close to
them during the performances and then
after kind of walk up walked up to them
and showed them a clue a lot of them had
pins or something on them to give away
some evidence we saw a moon pin for who
we believe is kandi and she actually had
a kind of NSFW song wimp Rasheeda in
2013 called legs to the moon listen like
I said not stay for work but I think it
proves our point yes absolutely
a lot to take in moving forward another
contestant who brought the heat and
certainly made me jealous of everyone in
the audience was the turtle check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
turtle giving it to us week after week
I'm still pulling for who I think is
Jesse McCartney to take this whole thing
you guys but let's get right into his
clue package tonight the turtle really
dedicated his his clue package to Robin
Thicke Robin you don't know how hard
I've been geeking out under this mask it
was so touching to see what an impact
judge Robin Thicke has had on the
turtles career and his sound and
influence so if you know anything about
Jesse McCartney you know he is 1,000% a
huge Robin Thicke fan in fact he
actually covered Robins song the stupid
things on his 2004 album beautiful soul
[Music]
don't you see like the parallels between
their voices like kind of high pitch
they really do that falsetto so
beautifully
I completely agree in since you said
beautiful soul I've been singing it in
my head for the past minute that that's
what Jesse McCartney does he gets stuck
in our brains that is right and moving
on to the closer luck clue tonight for
the turtle who we believe is Jesse
McCartney we saw a diamond ring pop
situation a very oversized ring finger
embellishment on that yes on that finger
Jesse actually got engaged to his
fiancee Katie Peterson in September so
this is something new and huge for him
and definitely a huge clue pointing to
his life yes and oh my goodness if this
is Jesse McCartney and he is planning a
wedding or planning to tie the knot my
heart goes out to him and his fiancee
because this quarantine situation is not
very conducive to a wedding so we are
thinking of you if it is you Jesse
McCartney we love you and moving on to
our final performer we have the Frog who
all just say it that performance was hip
hop hooray
[Music]
all right another week we're gonna sit
here and tell you why we think the Frog
is our pal so basketball has been a real
recurring theme in all of his clue
packages because so more of it tonight
on here's two reasons why number one
bow-wow has a song quite simply titled
basketball and then you remember bow-wow
from the movie like Mike which was very
focused around the theme basketball I
mean that locks it in for me all these
clues have certainly been pointing to
bow out I thought this one was actually
really cute his closer look pin was
something that just said mom and Robin
you know if you flip it upside down it's
wow but we're sticking with mom for this
one
his family has supported him through
through his career he has a very close
relationship with his mother who was
actually his momager for a good yeah of
his career which is so awesome did it
before Kris Jenner hey Jana bow-wow he
was only 16 years old spokes so so
highly of his mother on the Oprah
Winfrey Show
take a look know who's helping you
handle all of this oh my mother I mean I
gotta give all praise a guy my mother
most definitely because they really
watched out for me I mean that was so so
so sweet and he has stuck through and
through with his love for his mother and
all she's done for his career we
actually just saw on mother's day Baba
posted a video he surprised his mom with
a brand new 2020 BMW so I yeah I'm kind
of jealous to be honest gifting cars in
the middle of a pandemic that is a
loving dedicated second correct I think
that clue certainly points to Val's
mother
yes well Deidre like we just talked
about for this entire recap episode we
officially have our top three the neck
angel the turtle and the Frog moving on
to the season 3 finale I am so excited
but Deidre I need to know who's your
topic you should know by now I've been
going for the turtle the whole season I
think he is so diverse and so
interesting and has the vocal chops to
back it up who are you going for I'm
sticking with my queen herself the night
angel
I mean he's giving us charisma
uniqueness and telling every week out
there
garlis of who wins it's someone with
huge talent we've been watching this to
the show for so many weeks the cream
rose to the top and I just hope we get
shocking unexpected larger-than-life
performances next week is if the finale
you got to go big or go home go big or
go home and of course please keep
sending us your guesses your comments
who you think is gonna win this entire
competition next week in the grand
finale of season three yes the heat is
on the pressure is on and good news you
guys we will be speaking with the
eliminated contestants so get excited
for that send us your questions if you
have them and Charlie I miss you I miss
you and stick with us we'll be back next
week for a big finale episode have a
good one bye
[Music]